I'm not gonna say my name but I'm here
down with my people just like how
they're all here to stand with me yeah
they're all just gonna stop this
pipeline the reason I'm here it's just
to fight this is a very peaceful
demonstration but if need be you know
our people have been sitting in these
reservations you know in it it is
terrible you know and it's time for
these and justices and his Frosty's to
come about you know and we've been
pretty humble meet people all this time
kind of taken all of it and then all of
a sudden they just decided to mess with
the water you know when technology fails
there are no limits to what our
grandfathers can do when they take over
there's a lot of people that are
involved through this effort and they're
afraid of us they're afraid of the spare
we're gonna win I am thinking right now
what we're doing is they're feeding all
the people that are coming through
making sure everybody gets something to
eat we are prepared to be here for long
refrigeration we got water
we're not leaving we're staying here
this is where we live now how we go
ahead and get this black snake taken
care of this is where we live this guy
kind of want to seem like some spiritual
hello Maya
this is Peggy Luthor
it's red medicine I found her
yesterday as she's missing one of her
paws and she just called to me I'm not
only living for me I'm living for my
children my grandchildren I'll be able
to to say to them that I fought for you
that I laid down my life for you
that I loved you so much that I stood
against all odds and I fought for your
life and I fought for your water to make
sure that you were okay always a
multi-million dollar corporations all
this is money they don't see the future
of life the future of their own children
their own lives their cattle they're
going everything that they need to
survive is going to be dead
it's the fear of my children having
something able to drink you know able to
wash up you know able to cook with
that's why I'm here it's most important
thing and I understand why people don't
get that you know so that's why I'm here
is to protect our water and you know
I'll do it at all cost I'm prepared to
stay for the long haul
ain't nobody moving me